some candidates
unlike ron desantis do not have very
good political instincts i'm thinking in
particular i'm thinking of the
anti-desantis the opposite of ron
desantis namely
beetho o'rourke
loses the run for senate loses the run
for president now he's running for
governor of texas they do our work at
the moment
in which
the pro-life movement is probably at the
height of its influence at the moment in
which the pro-abortion movement is
probably at the absolute lowest point of
its influence among voters and among the
institutions beto o'rourke shows up to
the view to demand no limits on abortion
whatsoever
once the kid is born bye-bye baby i do
want to press further because you're a
progressive hero there are so many
people around the country who admire you
and your leadership do you believe in
any limit limitations on abortion
whether it's the third trimester or up
until even the final months nine months
i think roe versus wade which we should
remind ourselves is still the law of the
land today
is the the
the reference point that i would look to
and
the way i think i can best express this
is that i trust women we should all
trust women to make their own decisions
that are in their best interest for
themselves for their health care and for
their future that's the way it's been
literally my entire life i'm 49 years
old be 50 this year but that that's the
way it should be going forward um but
let me just finish this point super
quickly in in texas under greg abbott's
watch a hundred kids lost their lives
last year in the cps child protective
services system in texas under the care
and the custody of the state of texas if
he cared about life he would have cared
about those kids but he cares about
political points and control and power
over women's body he loves his guns
so pathetic
so weak coming from beto o'rourke if
listen there there is a very sad story
kids died in the foster care system and
if greg abbott really cared about life
he would have killed those kids much
sooner
he wouldn't have let those kids live for
however long they did live he would have
killed them much sooner that's how you
care about life why is he even talking
about the foster carers yeah you find me
a republican who thinks that the foster
care system is just perfect
or thinks that that uh there's there
there's no way to improve the foster
care give me a break
i don't know i don't there's no
republican there's a complete straw man
and if you really cared about no if you
listen buddy we're talking about
abortion and your view on abortion is so
hideous morally idiotic and unpopular
that you don't want to talk about
abortion and you want to move on and
talk about foster care okay you want to
talk about foster care let's talk about
foster care
i would love to reform the foster care
system i would love to make it easier
for parents to adopt and less expensive
for parents to adopt in this country i
would love to make it harder for parents
to get divorced in this country i would
love to do all sorts of things that
would help families in america i would
love to change
aspects of our industrial policy i would
love to change aspects of our trade
policy to make it easier to form
families i would love to do all sorts of
stuff if you want to have oh you don't
want to have that conversation now
you're talking about guns for some
reason joy bayer and we need to talk
about gun no you those are totally
separate issues i'm happy to talk about
guns too but you're all running away
from the issue of abortion because you
know that your position on it namely
that you should be able to kill a baby
one minute before he's born is extremely
unpopular and obviously evil and wrong
so they they keep trying to shift the
goal posts
this guy does not have good instincts
whenever beto o'rourke issues an opinion
on something if you are an aspiring
politician if you want to be effective
in the political square do the opposite
okay it's just
even regardless of what you think it is
a good bet that whatever beta or work
thinks the opposite is going to be more
politically effective turning now from a
terrible show to a good show from the
view to the joe rogan show joe rogan
expressed last week i meant to get to it
last week we can get to it now his view
on the abortion issue and i think his
view
is actually where a lot of americans are
on the issue joe rogan's view is i'm for
a woman's right to choose but
you know it's just
i just don't lie you know i don't like
people telling other people what they
can and can't do but it gets weird when
the baby gets like six months old you
know it gets weird when they're really
really pregnant because in some states
for the longest i don't know what the
rules are now but i know that some
states have late term abortions and
sometimes you need one for medical
reasons right like the woman could die
if she gives birth like it's a decision
that people have to make well if you
look back what was your favorite part of
being a fetus ah
well what was your favorite part of
being three you know should i be able to
shoot you at three because i don't want
to take care anymore it's one of those
things it's like i am 100 for a woman's
right to choose
but as a human being just as a just a
person observing things there's a big
difference between a little clump of
cells
and a fetus with eyeball and a beating
heart
and for anybody to pretend there's not
is it's
you're not doing any where do you draw
the line right where do you draw the
line yeah yeah that's the question
so joe's view here is
totally understandable i think it's
probably the majority of you in america
it it also is the least coherent view
so it
i think the pro-life view
and even the pro-abortion view you know
the pro-life view which is
if human life has worth it all it has
worth from the very beginning and we
should defend it
that makes sense
the pro-abortion view the the really
honest pro-abortion view which is yes
obviously the baby is a baby obviously
the baby is a human but we want women to
have maximal bodily autonomy and in
order for women to have the same degree
of bodily autonomy as men they need to
be able to kill their kids that's the
view popularized by naomi wolfe it's the
view popularized by that girl who came
on my show last week
that view i think it's ghastly i think
it's evil but i understand it
joe's view
is
it makes less sense but i i can
understand why people come along to it
which is
look i want i don't want to tell women
what to do i don't i want women to be
able to do whatever they want to do but
like come on it's at a certain point
it's obviously a baby right and it's
obviously wrong to kill babies and when
his guest makes that glib joke what was
your favorite part about being a fetus
joe mocks him for he says oh hahaha i
don't know what's your favorite part
about being three
should be like you know give me a break
man do you remember being two come on
come on that's that's such a weak
argument
but then joe says well there's a huge
difference between a clump of cells and
a
six-month-old baby in the womb but there
there isn't a total difference actually
there it you know the either they i
think that the the big differences here
the big distinguishing features are
are you alive are you a human
i think those are the difference between
alive and not alive the difference
between human and not human are much
bigger differences than say the
difference between having fully formed
hands and not fully formed hands between
having fully formed eyeballs and not
fully formed eyeballs those seem to me
they're differences but those are much
supe more superficial differences then
are you alive or are you not alive are
you human or are you not human joe is so
close he's so on the right track here
and he realizes that the pro-abortion
propaganda is bs now the only question
for him and really
you know i think he so expresses popular
views that it's a question for all of
america is are you going to go all the
way with your correct moral intuitions
or are you going to follow them to their
logical conclusion
i'm glad you like that clip now smash
and like and ring and click and hit the
whatever you know subscribe get the
notifications also head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play go
get the michael knowles show five-star
review maybe leave a 10 star review if
you don't mind we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]